haha do you want to watch Ninja Turtles
three-four tears ever seen
okay well Malcolm doesn't have any
weapons I don't have my nunchucks I
don't have my nunchucks do it
hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and my name is Malcolm Reich and today
we are watching Ninja Turtles three are
you see less than enthused yeah cuz I've
heard so much about it not being good I
also have heard when I said I was gonna
do Ninja Turtles one everyone's like
stay away from three mmm but the first
you were so serviceable I really hope
that it's like so bad it's good like
kind of fun right right that kind of fun
bad where it's like it's so bad that
it's actually kinda entertaining yeah I
will see you though I'm going to I'm I'm
positive I think this is gonna be fun
I am negative just like my test results
oh damn yeah we're starting on that
[Music]
what i am- ah it was way worse than I
expected you know I thought I was just
gonna be like more the same cheesy humor
and it was just gonna be like over the
top
this was actually underwhelming and
awkward and clunky it very much had the
vibe of like trying to be I don't
actually know which one came first but
trying to be Back to the Future 3 kind
of seemed like yeah yeah but they didn't
integrate the characters well at all
like they brought back Casey Jones yeah
but like Casey Jones and April O'Neil
had no reason to be there what it was
like not a Ninja Turtles movie yeah
exactly it's like let's just throw them
back in feudal era Japan for for shits
and giggles also there was no rapping
there was no rapping either fail there's
like the scepter that April just happens
to bring from a trinket store and the
rules of it don't make any sense
like it just zaps you back in time if
you're holding it and someone on the
other end of the the time thingy is
holding one but but then to switch back
they couldn't just reverse that because
to switch back they had to like send a
whole team back and it's like what but
yeah and yeah it was like did three
people just happen to be holding the
scepter in feudal era Japan
it didn't make any sense the story was
so convoluted like some kind of butyl
Lord and this pirate game and like
they're trading weapons and like there's
this princess or something and no love
like it didn't make sense
it was like let's go talk about the
really good costumes yeah right okay
like they're the set designs for the
feudal eras like that that was cool like
the costumes they're all good but like
the main issue which is you know the
main draw this movie are
ninja turties Johansson was clearly not
involved
well this at all Thanks animatronics on
the head were so sharp and aggressive
he's like that like I'm like dude yeah
say things and it's like that looks like
he was hard for you to say like you
struggled to get this work somehow
developed like a ton of weird spots
everywhere cuz they didn't have as many
spots in the place they look like they
had like just gotten like a disease like
they just struck with like turtle
syphilis like around the crotch in my
notes I wrote oh my god Casey Jones is
back hooray one of my favorite parts of
the first movie and then he's like a
glorified babysitter yeah and it was
weird also to see Casey and April O'Neil
together because it's different April
than in the first so you've never seen
them like interacting for it it's so
good and on the subject of Casey there
was also a feudal era Casey which you
couldn't really tell but they they kind
of ushered it in and that was
interesting but I'm trying to figure out
why he they did that because the the
backlash of the second for not having
Casey they're like we're just gonna put
him in a lot yeah Elijah he's gonna look
different in both versions this movie
was not working on many many levels it
just wasn't working the choreo upfront
was really cool I will say throughout
all three films I think that the best
part was seeing the turtles and actually
fight and like doom Coolio yeah
yeah the the choreo was really good the
stunt work like it was fine but it just
felt like it was unneeded like it felt
like there was no purpose behind the
fighting like I remember there was one
scene where they were literally trying
to deter a fight and Michelangelo was
like oh you dinged the show it's time to
get you know served or something and
it's just like wait what you you're
literally de-escalating the situation
now you're just gonna fight him because
he
to you in your indestructible shell oh
ok so one part they try to make a fake
scepter oh yeah and it's like a big
point in the film it takes like multiple
minutes to do and they're like making
this scepter and then it drops and
breaks and they immediately move on yes
move on I'm like you waste it like 30
minutes screen time no personality's was
another thing I wrote down like the
turtles could have been any of the
Turtles yeah yeah they were all just
literally replicas of each other you
don't get a sense of their individual
identities because they do have their
own identity and so with that with like
the no character development and not
showing the characters at all then being
in this weird out of character place
just really like multiply is that so
you're just watching it like good these
Ninja Turtles doing this times what what
is happening right now and it was a
short film it was like an hour and a
half
oh my god it felt like it was three
hours oh I felt long I wanted to start
doing this and Tara's never seen
episodes and be like if it's I'm happy
or if it should have just stayed that I
hadn't seen it and this is like a Tamra
should not have seen it was a mess and
everyone's twitter was saying that it
was gonna be a mess but I just I don't
know when you hear something is so bad
you kind of hope that if it's been
enough time that you can watch it with
like a tape like by taking a step back
you can watch it and like really enjoy
it right and this was not that I mean it
was really fun to watch with you and if
you weren't there
oh my god it would have been hard to
watch alone the pacing is so awkward
like you just like wait what what yeah
he just drops all of this information on
you like like if the movie opens up in
feudal era Japan you're like okay you're
trying to follow along but it just keeps
like introducing new elements without
you know really explaining and you don't
need to like spoon-feed it to him but
give us something like it's got a mimics
I know like after this like in the 90s
they decided to make a TV series
and they introduced a female turtle so
they can have sex I completely forget
what the storyline with that was because
I was watching the turtle sex have you
ever seen a video of turtles having sex
I know that's why I kind of have a small
aversion to turtles if I'm being
completely honest I remember watching a
video where this turtle was like
squeaking turtle was having sex I can
never get it out of my mind the sound
yeah oh no I don't think anything's ever
made me that uncomfortable spots pretty
sure brad has reviewed yeah you did
review a ninja turtles like porn yeah oh
we should watch that next camera's never
seen porn yeah nothing can connect it or
mattered why didn't April talk about a
story once she literally never talks
about her her job she never there's no
reason for her specifically to be there
yeah they could have done something to
introduce that septa to like she could
have been doing this story on like a
museum exhibit would have been so easy
there's no reason for for Casey Jones to
be there which is such a sad thing
because in the first film my favorite
characters were Casey and April and so
for them to just be like thrown away
also this is the creator of Ninja
Turtles this is his favorite film of the
three I thought it was more true to to
the cat cartoon
at least I read that somewhere yeah
maybe not that's a weird internet rumor
right well thank you so much for joining
me I wish we had never seen this film
total job cow a bogus bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you